Speaker 1: One of the things we've talked
about on the show for a long time is that
there seems to be something sort of constitutional
that's lowercase C. I mean, with the constitution
of the of the right, the way the right is,
where a sort of like satire, parody and to
some degree, comedy.
Are just sort of like not working on the right,
and so an example of that would be this there
is this old show that was supposed to challenge
Jon Stewart's The Daily Show years ago.
It was called the half hour news hour.
And it it just wasn't funny and it failed
very, very quickly.
And we've seen a lot of these right wing comedians
just fail to be comedians and the new like
least funny man in America now is this guy
named Jim Breuer.
Now we've talked about Jim Breuer before.
He's become kind of like an anti-vax laugh
at Foushee, laugh at science type of right
right wing comedian.
And it's like, What does that even mean at
this point in time?
And he really seems to have kind of lost his
grip with reality.
There's a new video that was published by
the Reawaken America American Faith Tour.
This is, he's been going around with this
like religious revival kind of tour, and we
played a clip of that in the past, and he
did a video for them where he's now talking.
I guess this is I don't even know what he's
talking about.
I guess this is supposed to be a commentary
on Joe Rogan and foreign policy, although
it's hard to tell what this is.
But the right thinks that this is funny, whereas
I see a guy who's lost his connection to reality,
probably worthy of a psych eval.
Take a look at this.
I think they think this is funny.
Maybe the voices are supposed to be funny.
Speaker 2: What happened was people like 80
were, you know, did you see that?
And also, like Rush Hour wants to go to war.
And people, I do.
They really want to go to war.
They.
You know what?
No more mandates.
Maybe some mandates put out, you know,
Speaker 1: like, what is the critique here
is the critique that there are things in the
news like, I am not.
I don't know what is what is the point here.
Speaker 2: The problems are about how they
are losing grip.
Speaker 1: The right loves this guy.
I'm going to show you a video in a second
where they're in hysterics.
It's almost like, do you normally watch paint
dry to the point where this is entertaining?
Speaker 2: But beware, because when you're
in power that long, you're not going down
without a vicious, foaming at the mouth battle.
And I don't know what that's going to do.
I mean, I see it now they're trying to do
to Joe.
This is a psychological war.
It is an American war.
When the White House says we need to censor.
A human being that allows conversations.
Guess what, everyone, you just been taken
over and you're just sitting there taking
it and you can buy all you want that.
Oh, well.
And then when it doesn't sell, they send their
stars.
Speaker 1: What on earth is this guy talking
about?
I mean, really like if the point of that is
to defend Rogan, I don't know that that's
very helpful to Rogan, to be perfectly honest.
It just seems like the rantings of an unhinged
person.
Just as a reminder, this was Brewer's in-person
performance at this American Faith Reawaken
America tour, talking about Fauci and some
other things.
And if you're watching, you'll see that the
crowd is in hysterics.
Are these must be the most sheltered people
in the world to find this funny?
Speaker 2: You know what?
A cockatoo is a cockatoo.
Look at the crowd.
And that's what everyone's become.
Right?
Little cockatoos staring at the screen.
Facts and figures.
Dr Back, take that back.
Speaker 1: Whoa.
I guess you're right.
Masks must not work based on this routine
right now.
Disclaimer?
I'm not saying masks don't work.
Just to be clear, I don't want to end up getting
in trouble myself.
Speaker 2: I trust the science.
The science.
Speaker 1: Now, as I've said before, he did
trust the science when sadly his wife needed
cancer treatment, and he said with no hint
of irony, we are trusting the science.
We're finding the best specialists, we're
finding the people who know about this stuff.
That's who we're following.
We're not following Hannity recommending zinc
or, you know, whatever.
So he's also a complete and total hypocrite.
But the right finds this funny, and that should
scare us as much as anything else we see going
on right now within that right wing cultural
movement.